has been participating in Cuban
elections for decades she says her
family was among the poorest in the
country and benefited from Fidel
Castro's Revolution
now she says soaring prices are a major
challenge for Cuba's government and
that's why its leadership needs more
support than ever we need to work so we
confront the difficult time so we can
produce more for the country we have
lots of educated people after the
pandemic lots of people are struggling
and for a country like ours with an
embargo it's worse
millions of Cubans headed to the polls
on Sunday to elect the members of the
National Assembly that will select the
next president
Cuba is a one-party system the
candidates for the National Assembly are
selected by a commission loyal to the
Communist Party there's 472 candidates
for 472 seaters no members of the
opposition and that's why critics say
that Cubans are allowed to vote but not
to choose disenchment with the economic
situation is everywhere to be seen U.S
sanctions power cuts a 60 inflation rate
this year and shortages of almost
everything have forced hundreds of
thousands to leave the country
and that's why turnout is crucial for
the government to provide the new
assembly with a legitimacy it needs to
rule in times of trouble
there are a lot of people that will not
vote to punish the government because
it's a fact that a government in the
middle of a crisis is a government that
gets punished but at the same time the
new National Assembly needs to get
involved in the day-to-day problems
people face and get into a debate forum
but not everyone is convinced thousands
of people took to the streets in July
2021 in the largest anti-government
protests in years
they were demanding Freedom hundreds
were detained and remain in prison
medium Leiva has been an outspoken
critic of Cuba's government her husband
spent years in prison
the Cuban reality doesn't need to be
exaggerated because it's tragic after
years it's my duty to say the truth the
situation is so difficult that we have
to see how the government solves this
and opens up because there is one
reality the control here is not in a
civilian government but in the hands of
the military and now more than ever
the government is promising to improve
the country's devastated economy
millions in Cuba are waiting for those
reforms that will provide the relief
that many here so desperately need Cuba